hello freak [ __ ] it's just like that
it's just one of those things remember
when people were wearing those Holograms
attached to a rubber band around their
wrists and do you member these stupid
[ __ ] things
do you remember him Jamie you remember
him right Gwyneth Paltrow's got in
trouble for selling him on her like well
this damn [ __ ] [ __ ] and thing no
offence squared its but III might have I
might have said some mean things about
Glenn oh my god been a couple of things
about her lately in her [ __ ] nutty
website she takes you're supposed to
wear like a rock inside your vagina oh
one of those awesome I call them [ __ ]
rock yeah [ __ ] rocks are hilarious
oh I guess it would like strengthen you
it's if you want to strengthen it just
to kegels around a dick that's my
success mic method for temporary life
rocks a good way to go glass Paltrow
wants to heal you with magic stickers
change Christ's babies she needs
getting paid though tell you that
there's a lot of dummies out there
either SOT nomming all the way she an
ATM machine she is proof that [ __ ]
sells way better than science I'm I do
not have her hurt salary oh wait a
minute could rebalance the energy
frequency I didn't know that hold on a
second she discovered something about
stickers you should take these stickers
if they're made with the right material
you just put them on your body in the
right places and they in quotes
rebalance the energy frequency in our
bodies yeah hmm now made out of a NASA
spacesuit material and NASA said it was
a load of BS but hold on a second I
don't think the NASA is right when it is
in a bunch of movies and Iron Man about
science
it says Gwyneth Paltrow's goop website a
lifestyle business lifestyle which tells
all things with advertised these
stickers are using NASA spacesuit
material which presumably was the source
of their magic healing properties jesus
[ __ ] christ she's special the
stickers are not made this is what NASA
says they're not made of spacesuit
material not that's based in new suit
material it has healing properties in
the first place it doesn't but the quote
from the former NASA scientist mark
Scholl shell hem countless shell Homer
Elmer Shalimar sums it up
heels wow what a load of BS this is or
that yeah okay she obviously grew
quickly updated it site now it doesn't
claim anything about NASA spacesuits and
stickers but it didn't dial back and in
the magical healing claims here's what
goop says now in an article called
wearable stickers that promote healing
in parentheses really you [ __ ] human
bodies operate an ideal energetic
frequency but every day stress is an
anxiety you give me stress you [ __ ]
I can throw off our internal balance
depleting our energy reserves and
weakening our immune system [ __ ]
imagine thinking that you could put a
sticker on you and it's going to heal
you body vibe stickers oh my god they're
called body bugs come in pre-pro they
come pre-programmed
I'll [ __ ] their programming program I
didn't know that to an ideal frequency
allowing them to target imbalances you
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] crook don't you have enough
money [ __ ] it's just hair right
apparently the the residuals on the Iron
Man movies just weren't enough for her
god damn 60 bucks for a tenfold [ __ ] ten
stickers for 60 buckets oh my god I am
in the wrong industry apparently I need
to start selling some fancy [ __ ]
stickers no you don't okay look look
this is a very this is a very
controversial subject right like
anything that's not regulated by the FDA
like I I'm a part of an interest of full
disclosure a part of the company on it
which is a we sell supplements but the
supplements that we sell we control
everything that we sell so we make sure
that we do testing on it the supplements
we sell like this [ __ ] alpha brain did
do two double-blind placebo-controlled
studies at Boston Center for memory this
showed increase in verbal memory
increase in there's a bunch of different
things uh what was the other one um
there was a reaction time but as a whole
there's actual scientific studies on
nootropics they've been around for a
long time I'm either earliest about them
just because I haven't looked into them
enough and I know they're kind of
they're new ish you know into the
supplement market so like I kind of want
to look into them and I don't know
after comment essentially the building
blocks for human neurotransmitters what
your body uses the nutrients your body
uses to make human neurotransmitters
there's nothing Loulou about it nothing
crazy it's all backed by science but
when we started putting them out there's
a lot of people that were claiming
[ __ ] you're selling snake oil so we
had to control these studies and we had
to you know pay for them at the Boston
center for memory yeah and put we also
had to make sure that we put a full 100%
money-back guarantee on any supplements
where you don't have to return them just
say they didn't work for you we're try
and like make it as clean as possible
this is stuff that I use I find benefit
in it let's see you know like what
people think about it and let's make
sure that we have studies but when you
sell things like stickers like there's
no [ __ ] Studies on stickers and what
adulteress said like when she was on
Kimmel a few weeks ago and he was like
so how does work eventually just came
out and said I don't know how any of the
[ __ ] works it's like yeah because you're
selling rocks for your policy does she
have somebody else that does it maybe in
there just unscrupulous and no in the
part of it she's a CEO and she's
apparently in all the meetings was busy
reading it's reading scripts and [ __ ]
look at this one look at this
anti-anxiety unicorn scared the beach
beauty sleep wait a minute
one of each vibe one of the vibes is at
the beach chill July that's at the
pre-programmed it chilled for for
self-love one of them is chilled for
unicorn skin it's a real love I demand
an orgasm within three minutes I don't
think it works that way I am yeah I
don't I don't good about yourself
doesn't gala crock rocked out bliss it
[Applause]
[Music]